[Music]
the practice that for me has
really helped reduce stress and allowed
me to
fall asleep more easily and control my
state of mind late in the evening is
this practice that some people call yoga
nidra which literally means yoga sleep
and that practice of taking 20 or 30
minutes a day and it doesn't have to be
done every day
and lying down and doing a sort of body
scan
it involves some long exhale breathing
which is very relaxing to the nervous
system
and really allowing the mind to enter
one of these pseudo sleep states
we know from work in my laboratory and
work that i'm doing with david spiegel's
laboratory as well as work from other
labs
that that state of
shallow nap or shallow sleep done in
waking
allows the brain to
and the person to get better at turning
off their thoughts and falling asleep in
the evening so i use both behavioral
tools and
pharmacology which of course is really
what supplementation is
i don't have any problem
with buffering cortisol a little bit in
the short term so doing that for a week
or two but i wouldn't suggest
that people
suppress their cortisol
long term unless there's a real clinical
need to do that
long term being longer than two weeks
you mentioned long exhales
in the context of the yoga nidra
practice
is it fair to refer to that yoga nidra
practice is also
non-sleep deep rest or nsdr are those
separate phenomena
yeah so yoga nidra is one of several
what we call nsdr non-sleep deep rest
protocols admittedly i coined the term
nsdr because scientists like acronyms
almost as much as the military likes
acronyms and i did it deliberately
not to rob
the beautiful
history and community that is yoga nidra
and the yogic communities of anything
but rather because many people are
averse to doing anything that has a name
like yoga nidra and yet it's such a
powerful tool it's a zero cost tool that
has enormous effects on not just
accessing sleep and calm but enhancing
rates of neuroplasticity something that
we could talk more about also david
spiegel
again our associate chair of psychiatry
at stanford and close collaborator and
friend of mine
is a world expert in clinical hypnosis
we are part of a just in in full
disclosure we both sit on the advisory
board of a company called reverie
r-e-v-e-r-i
dot com reverie is a zero-cost app
beyond android and apple that
has short hypnosis protocols anywhere
from
10 minutes to 15 minutes
hypnosis and yoga nidra both fall under
the umbrella of nsdr non-sleep deep
breast and these are protocols that
people can use to deliberately access
states of deep rest for sake of again
falling asleep more easily reducing
stress but also for enhancing rates of
learning of neuroplasticity and because
these are zero cost tools i and because
they're grounded in excellent
peer-reviewed research i feel
comfortable mentioning them
and what you find is that
if people who are not familiar with
meditation or mindfulness or maybe
they're not from west la or the bay area
um if they hear yoganidra they think
magic carpets and they think and they
hear hypnosis and they think that
somebody's going to control their brain
nsdr is my attempt
to create a more friendly language
which is because all of these things are
really just the same thing they really
involve two things one
self-directing a state of calm that's
something that we never learned how to
do unless we have a need to do it we
suffer some trauma we have chronic
stress we start taking a mindfulness
class we self-inducing a state of calm
through respiration and vision is the
hallmark of yoganidra and hypnosis and
frankly of all meditative practices
our thoughts follow our vision and
breathing and i can explain why that is
in a moment
in addition
these nsdr type practices
involve not just self-directing calm but
they also involve directing our focus to
something
we generally have a hard time falling
asleep because we think we have to turn
off our thoughts completely like a
switch but the transition to sleep
involves allowing our thoughts to become
fragmented and then we become relaxed
and then the brain enters the state
where space and time are very fluid and
not under our conscious control and
those are things that we can teach
ourselves so yoga needs your scripts are
found all over
youtube there's some great apps out
there the zero cost ones that i use are
any of the stuff by comedy
k-a-m-i-n-i desai d-e-s-a-i i like her
voice very much some people like my
sister loves liam gillen's voice another
zero cost yoga nidra tool liam gillen
double l-g-i-l-l-e-n
you have to find a voice that you like
the revery app is david's voice
he has a very hypnotic voice
and there are scripts in there for
smoking cessation stress and anxiety
sleep etc these i really want to
emphasize in addition to being zero
costs are very powerful tools if done
regularly there are two papers that were
published in the last two years from
cell reports and cell press journal
excellent journal showing that a
20-minute non-sleep deep breath protocol
after a bout of intense focus or intense
attempt to learn anything skill learning
or cognitive learning
accelerates plasticity by about 50
so you are learning faster much faster
and retention of that information
lasts much longer and that's because
these are sleep-like states and we know
that neuroplasticity the brain's ability
to change in response to experience is
triggered by
high focus by deliberate periods of very
high focus but the actual rewiring of
neurons the formation of new synapses
and the reordering of the circuitry that
leads to that skill or that cognitive
ability becoming reflexive
that happens in states of deep rest
and non-sleep deep breast nsdr whether
it's hypnosis or yoganidra or a shallow
nap of about 20-30 minutes
those things will all accelerate
learning
you